cowboys and aliens is definitely
something unique look all films are high
concept at their core especially the big
popcorn movies I don't care what you
call it I don't care how you explain it
away you're taking an intrinsically
ridiculous concept and then bringing
bringing it to the screen and adding
reality to it in the case of cowboys and
aliens we just went ahead and called it
cowboys and aliens we didn't try to come
up with some sophisticated name to bury
what it is and that's kind of a new a
new wave of approach is to you know boom
it's there it's snappy you're curious
you don't know if it's a comedy if it's
silly if it's and and when we were
considering should we change the name
that was the name on the graphic novel I
said the Harrison Ford I say you know
people are kind of giving us some given
us some about the name some people
love it but some people really are
confused or offended by it I said should
we change the name and he thought for a
second he went well what the hell else
would you call it the alien aspect of
cowboys and aliens is what allowed us to
make a Western on the scale of the old
westerns in recent times you have great
westerns like True Grit or Unforgiven
but those are films that are done those
are smaller films that that reach out to
a larger audience because of their
quality and how well they were
accomplished but in the old days
westerns were the action film they were
the popcorn fill them that era and by
having Cowboys and Aliens sci-fi is the
popcorn film of this era so by having
the scope of a sci-fi film but the genre
of a Western gives it a certain classic
look and feel ironically and so our
generation now is getting an opportunity
through a film at Cowboys and Aliens to
make a statement about our generation
you deal with the classic archetypes you
deal with the classic story lines and
you twist it and you use the movie stars
of your era to retell the stories that
have been told decade after decade and
as a filmmaker it's a it's a tremendous
I appreciate the opportunity so much I
think you you know what's nice about i
think that the statement that this one
ultimately embraces is by having an
extraterrestrial force you're no longer
coming to terms with the complexity of
the xenophobia that was related by the
first half of the last century not to
get too heady about the whole thing the
Native Americans were not viewed as a
culture that that the Europeans
understood they were being painted as
this mysterious evil force and as each
generation developed and we learn more
about Native American culture with the
searchers Cheyenne autumn Dances with
Wolves we began to understand that they
were actually the underdogs in many
situations and the classic black and
white Western of good and evil was
outdated when you have an
extraterrestrial threat you're creating
an enemy and so you can go back on all
of the old western tropes from a simpler
time without being ignorant to the
cultural impact of it because you can
create an evil as deep deeply black as
you want and to do that we drew from the
old masters of the horror sci-fi genre
when you look at you know alien and
aliens and predator and and I wouldn't
even limit it to that I would look at
jaws and I would look at all of the
films and that pre cg you know hybrid
horror era where you were using the
imagination of the audience as your most
powerful special effect technically it
was more much more difficult than let's
say iron man where we were shooting up
essentially plates of a background and
having some explosions but then having
CG characters
dealing with one another fighting
talking flying in this we had to
actually create interactions between men
on horseback some cases thrown rope
shooting getting attacked and knocked
over all of those things had to occur in
a real place and be planned ahead of
time and then ILM would then add the
aliens into it so getting the aliens
photo-real in daylight we're able to do
that now it's a it's a classic story
whether it's magnificent seven seven
samurai it's the Bandit horde that has
to be held off by the you know by the by
the by the weird collection of warriors
and and and and civilians and it's a
throwback to the old old style of
storytelling using extremely modern
techniques